[Music]
in finally free news submitted by who is
who
a couple spent 21 years in prison after
being falsely accused of child abuse do
you know me to begin life again
21 years falsely accused how's this
possible
yeah the child did it hey babysitter
yeah oh my god that's scary yeah it is
scary
you see nanny cams plea when they abuse
the kids that shit's sad oh my god they
also have some nanny cam shoot were they
like all the picking dogs and [ __ ]
Oh or the elderly yeah the elderly a
part of me wants to have a nanny cam so
I could catch them by hitting my kid so
I could [ __ ] them up and have a reason
to do it so I just wait sit there just
please to strike my child's like a
destroy you please hit my kid and I put
like a really like like a red shirt on
your kid yeah make it more hittable
let it be permanent brain damage like a
real I don't know about that just give
him like a light smack so I could just
knock the [ __ ] out of you yeah so good
couple your name is Dan and Fran Dan and
for you how could they hit a child I
don't see that name Dannan friend to
that balls yeah no that's the way around
a daycare center in Austin Texas in the
90s so at the time of this whole scandal
bless you
they were in the 40s and 50s at that
time but now they're 75 and 67 they old
millions of dollars they were convicted
of sexual assault in 1992 what the only
piece of evidence was an apparent wound
on one of the children's vagina this
turned out to be wrong though because
the doctor who testified later denied
his confidence in the assessment oh
Jesus
the case was finally dismissed this year
in June 21 years 21 years and they were
like branded us like Chad Raber
the worst thing to be branded on for a
day Kelly if you had sent your kid to
that daycare you're like your life's
over dude I'm sure is pretty crazy
so at that time there was like
widespread panic about satanic activity
and it began sometime in the 80s so by
the time this is happening there's still
a lot of people that thought like Oh
everyone's a devil worshiper so there
was a witch hunt going on in Texas in
the country really it was like a lot of
people believed everybody's a devil
worshiper yeah so the children from that
daycare they accused Dan and Fran of
lacing their kool-aid with blood wearing
white robes cutting the heart out of the
baby flying children to Mexico to be
raped by soldiers we're burying children
alive with animals throwing them in a
pool with sharks wait the children
accuse them shooting them and
resurrecting them afterwards that's what
the children were saying so what kind of
[ __ ] demonic children are telling
them about devil worshippers and stuff
they do and then yeah because a lot of
these kids they were there were being
interviewed by said caught psychiatrists
and people and I just were convinced
that this couple or they were devil
worshippers and so you're like feeding
them yeah it seemed like the parents or
the psychologists like they were just
like trying to get it out of them and so
they come up with this [ __ ] [ __ ] so did
the kids grow up and be like none of
that [ __ ] happened well the thing is
because the kids would be like 28 now
yeah they're like I was never touched i
I just thought I was supposed to say
that [ __ ] it seems like these kids or
like they've been convinced of it
because now that they've been released
it's been reported that some of these
children are against their release they
are just brainwashed like they're I
personally feel like yeah we just got
brainwashed wait the evidence countering
this though is that the doctor says
maybe his testimony wasn't great is that
all the evidence Karen knows yeah
because there's nothing else oh there
was nothing else no other proof so you
would think there's bodies blood they
find some sort of you name this thing
children is one of those big evidences
it's pretty good well they're talking
about killing them and resurrecting them
so it's like demonic
yeah or like sending them off to get
raped laughter sounds like it's like
fables in the community
where they were convicted of those
things no yeah they were just convicted
at one particular laceration yes so the
thing is this all started from a single
accusation of a 3 year old girl she had
known behavioural problems and she was
claiming that Dan was hurting her this
other girl was claiming that Dan had
went to her house took a chainsaw to her
dog's vagina then took the girl to a
cemetery where they threw a person in a
hole shot the person and cut up the body
where the children went while the
children helped that's what that one
girl was clear she's three it's not
specified that that three-year-old said
that but they're just saying like it was
good that's some [ __ ] crazy-ass
imagination so that girl is now a serial
killer well they're saying that a lot of
these children that were sent in my
worried parents to talk to these
therapists that these therapists
apparently were quacks they thought that
they could dig up past traumas through
hypnosis oh yeah that was a thing I
don't there appear [ __ ] hate that the
police actually flew over that cemetery
that this girl was saying that all this
should happen and they did find a
gravesite that what had fresh dirt and
so they use that in the trial but what
they didn't mention in the trial was
that once they investigated that they
found out that there was a grave that
kept sinking yeah like it wouldn't say
level for some reason so that a family
member of that person that was buried
there they would constantly come over
and put fresh dirt on on that grave but
they didn't really mentioned that during
the trial show they were just so
convinced that you conveniently left
that part out yeah exactly it's like a
perfect storm of shitty thing is it it
was so they basically which haunted this
nice little couple that was running a
daycare yes and he just loved kids and
whatever all these years in prison
they're saying that Fran described how
she was always targeted in prison
because because people thought that she
hurt kids yeah yeah and so like she
would dodge boiling water and shanks and
they she just had to dodge conscious
constant abuse oh my gosh and she wasn't
allowed to be with Dan obviously no for
those for those over 20 years
this is why maybe we take a little far
sometimes guys on the show when we're
like I don't care they should be killed
immediately yeah I don't care what they
did they should be killed like if
they're doing that to kids or whatever
it's like oh [ __ ] wait wait wait this
could happen - no but if it's to save
kids do you think in that time that was
like when all these cults kind of
started coming to light like Charles
Manson from the 70s or whatever like it
just kept getting more and more like
known cuz like I was definitely during
that time where everyone drink kool-aid
and like the Halley's Comet thing happen
what blows my mind is how the [ __ ] is a
three year old better than me at torture
techniques how the [ __ ] how would they
even know like this man brought a
chainsaw
put it to my vagina threatened the dogs
would you get the dog
dude Stephen King reads this [ __ ] he's
like whoa yeah they shot this boy
brought him back to [ __ ] life and we
have to witness it I feel like you see
things in movies or TV shows or
something and then you like you just
your imagination yeah but I don't think
I was that dog so they were actually
sentenced for 48 years each their story
resurfaced in 2009 where the Austin
Chronicle wrote an article about them
and then that's when a lawyer saw this
article and they were like hold on like
there's nothing that really cements
these people even did any of these
ridiculous things so then this lawyer
started helping this couple turn and get
them out of prison and so finally the
case was appealed in 2013 they were just
saying the figure you know that you
apologize for everything that they've
been through and so finally we're gonna
get the key to the city that's pretty
great yeah mistakes happen right sorry
yeah they also recently in June they
finally declared them completely
innocent and finally dismissed the case
completely they were awarded 3.4 million
dollars from the state fund for being
wrong
I enough all of your life from like ten
years old till now within prison
like that's how much time they took from
you oh yeah like from when you were ten
years old till now yeah it's how much
you like you missed out on well they
missed some good ones too man
like what was it there 360 now no
there's 70 something 75 when there were
5000 suns your life is like done now
yeah I was here she didn't have any kids
became it's been that money skydiving
[ __ ] when they were convicted you know
what they look like John to them yeah
yeah it's like it's stupid we don't know
anything actually he does it because the
eyebrows and you know nah they don't
they need mugshot pictures for me to
identify because I'll tell you even if
they got away and they're actually they
were molesters I'd be able to tell why
from the face you can't even win at
mafia come on I know he gets killed too
quickly so how do they maintain their
marriage in prison he's like pen pal
chat or maybe they visit the whole time
from the time that they were released up
until recently they were finally awarded
they had to like scramble to get by like
family helping them and they couldn't
get it become kind of job because
they're like no one's gonna hire a child
abuser
even though very good boo names nothing
by the way even foreign far former child
abusers like that [ __ ] sticks it doesn't
matter
people keep it in the back of their head
every time I'm talking to you they think
maybe you did it maybe you did it
especially with stories like that like
they chopped a body up into pieces and
3.4 million enough nah make a bag
groceries at my grocery shop if I had
one
everything we're unionized I hope you
guys enjoy this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]